[Music]
this is a meeting of the turrets council
community resources committee the main
management
oh well
welcome again to everyone
uh we'll move right on to the agenda
apologies for absolutely yes chairman
apology councillor brenton
councillor brown thank you i noticed
councillor pennington's here just
watching not
representing
no i i'm just i'm interested in all the
items that come up later on share okay
and i can't sit because i want scrutiny
i didn't know
right we move on to minutes of the last
meeting held on the 25th of april
i'm going to go through it from the
bottom pages
looking for comments and criticisms page
3
4
5
6.
all happy
can i have a proposal there accepted
councillor james seconded by chancellor
locke
all in favor please show
that is unanimous
um
[Music]
no comments there to anywhere
proper job public contributions it was
got me no
i may need to make this the quickest cmr
[Music]
inherently is anyone anything they wish
to add on to it or make comment to
no
proper job
item five declarations of interest
you're all senior counselors you know
the score
if you're involved in something you
should declare it now
item six agreement of the agenda between
parts one and two there is nothing
scheduled for part two
uh i would say to members of the public
that if we move into particularly
confidential affairs personal affairs or
financial that's when we go into part
two but we're not threatening to do it
tonight
item seven parity matters of information
we have nothing from this end
so item eight
leasehold disposal of part of the sports
ground kingsley road
um
that's going to be
sean dealing with it
thank you so so last year we were
approached by jurassic fiber uh telecoms
provider
about sighting a telecoms compound in
part of the sports ground and normally
we wouldn't deal with those these sorts
of negotiation in this way by bringing a
report because they have all sorts of
powers
to cite these installations uh but
because of the field and trust or king
george for the status of the site is
best that this is done in this way
we've managed to negotiate the site of
the compound and that's identified in
the report it's an area in the corner by
these um
skatepark
the lease
sum has been negotiated 15 000 pounds
for a 15-year term
and
the terms of release and plan commission
have already been negotiated and
represented for you to see
so that just brings us to the
recommendation
uh after consideration we would like to
recommend to you
that uh the detailed disposal of the
small parcel of land within the sports
ground kinky road as detailed in the
report
is agreed and
you can see the associated documentation
thank you
yeah tom phillips did consult me on this
one when it was going on
and whether we liked it or not were
caught by the new communications act a
couple of years ago
where the power is worth the acquiring
authority not with us unfortunately
so tom's done a tidy deal in those
circumstances
counselor laws first and just a point of
clarification instead of fields in trust
i thought that would totally preclude us
from selling any part of that
so
we're not prepared we're not proposing
to sell the land as a leasehold disposal
and then there's a compensatory some in
there agreed with fields and trust for
the exclusion thank you
yeah
i'm happy thank you
councillor
um
clearly we we have some position
uh in this um
lab otherwise you know we wouldn't have
been negotiating for um
you know a fee
of fifteen thousand pounds it's wonder
how we've got to fifteen thousand pounds
because it seems
a ridiculously cheap
a small sum of money for what's involved
here these high-tech communication
companies i know that they've got um
statutory rights etc but you know that
works at a thousand pound a year which
seems
almost like you give it a number three
so if i could ever answer on that
appreciate that
i think i can probably answer it as well
as anyone
all my landlord clients with
communications installations on their
farms are not happy bunnies with what
they're receiving either
but the government forced this through
under pressure from the
providers it was a case of providers
against landowners and the government
went with the providers
and we are stuck with it unfortunately
so the fee is effectively fixed by
in effect yes you can't be worried about
it you know if you had a prime site you
could go for thousands
well yes i asked a question but i know
someone that's got a
an old tele telecommunication
communications master
fairly cross
and you know they've got a you know a
very very substantial
annual payment to them he'll be fine
until it comes to the next renewal
and then he'll be spitting nails like
the rest
counselor pennington
christopher christie's only committee
i'm not in the committee chair
yeah your hand was up earlier that's why
i'm thank you okay i just following all
that's the very questions i wanted to
ask
because it seems very small money
for such a big
opportunity for jurassic to go forward
we have no right of appeal whatsoever
nope oh we can take it to appeal there
is an appeal system through the land so
the
lower courts
very expensive okay and the cases that
have been taken have been very
successful so we've done a course
benefit
check then basically yes we have so tom
wasn't happy with this he discussed with
me and
i provided him with my professional body
information on it and
the second point was our reason why it
came up with planning
we are not at any risk if it floods
because it is in the plane where it's
too they're probably not ours
good thank you chair for let me speak
councillor christie
thank you um
what when i first looked at this i
thought all right
i'll see why they want to put it there
but it didn't raise the issue of the
skateboard part because you know we've
had quite a few issues with use at night
and the idea was to keep that open at
the front so the police could go by and
keep an eye on it again we seem to be
putting a fence
um across part of the um side is that
correct and
the section where the compound will sit
is already behind the wall so it's next
to where the the football stand is and
the fence runs up dividing the football
ground and the skatepark so it sits in
the corner there there's already a wall
there so it's not in the open section so
the visibility visibility will be the
same as it currently is right because
when i looked up when i looked at the
plan we've been given it seems to go
quite a long way up actually i
i think
it won't actually
visually impair
no concerns you been raised yet
[Music]
okay
no one else wishing to speak on it can i
have a proposal one way or another
councillor james i propose we accept the
recommendation except the recommendation
is for a secondary councillor lock
all in favor please show
one two three four five six seven eight
those against
one
abstaining
none
okay
so we now move on to
the
last item on the agenda you're not tired
out yet
uh item nine
motion for the ocean pages 31 to 34.
let's thank chair i think councillor
hudson would like to say but it's uh
noticeable proposed and uh forwarded to
you from the council
all right thank you very much uh sean
um it gives me great pleasure to bring
this to you
it was heard at length
even though
it was just briefly alluded to because
that was wouldn't have been compliant
with
uh no cities of motion
we have discussed this and you have had
a very full report
um prepared for you to present this
motion from the ocean
and i can commend every aspect of this
to you all
and ask for your support for it
the ocean is very important to all of us
not just for
clean bathing waters
the reduction in pollution
[Music]
the fisheries um
agriculture
it is important for our livelihoods and
our
employment with tourism
if we don't have clean waters we're not
going to have people swimming we're not
going to have people choosing to come to
our area for holidays
and the businesses that depend on it
um
the most important thing is we have
new technology coming our way
with marine technology and the
development of middle dawn
so all these things dovetail together
to make us a clean environment a healthy
environment and hopefully a more
prosperous environment
um
the report makes certain recommendations
several of which were already have in
place
we have
beach cleans we have
the first
village to actually declare
it being
plastic free and
polystyrene surfboard free in westwood
home
and there's been huge amount of work
done there we also partner with the
biosphere
and the work that they are doing to
safeguard our coastal waters
so all in all the things that we come
with these recommendations
are finally list two
right to government asking them to
consider
the
issues uh that are listed here
now
the
local authority specialist
interest group for coastal communities
actually um joins with
forces with
government advisory groups and sits on
those
and we can give them more strength by
signing up with a lot of other coastal
communities that have already
adopted this notice of motion and
give that more strength to add to their
pleas for more involvement in government
to actually protect our islam and our
coastal communities
so i leave it to you to uh
hopefully not ask too many awkward
questions but uh i'm sure sure gonna
answer those
electricity
yeah i'm all in favor of this i think
council hodgson was proposing it i hope
she was yeah i second it um but it does
rather
uh focus
our attention on the future of the tip
on northern burrows because that is the
biggest single uh
well threat to the ocean in this area
when i read um the report some years ago
now on the
job field
the um pebble ridge we were told then
the pedal ridge is swinging on its axis
and it was actually going out on the
north and coming in on the south
could we if we accept this motion could
we actually look at that again and can
we ask presumably i think they're doing
some sort of studying could we ask them
what is actually happening because that
report i read it is about 15 years old
now
and there may be time
enough time has gone by to see if it is
actually happening
counseling look
yeah i mean i think it ties in really
well with
all the great plans the middle dot my
only concern is um will it affect
perhaps in years to come whether we can
have any wind um turbines out in the
ocean or if this um pipeline comes
across from morocco would that affect
that or would that still be allowed to
happen
[Music]
more detail to you next week will be
about how we use
those types of project to improve
the biodiversity oceans
and so you know how do you
use these installations to create extra
habitats how do you make these uh
these projects create pollution
improvements um so i would hope not so
it's the answer to the question okay
include laws
thank you just to go back to address
being ticked bishop
is constantly in touch with
and it has to be noted that
the
proposed
extension to the
see more effectively
the club prevention scheme that the ea
uh
forward
is being forwarded with more and more
urgency
where that is if you can address
the wall
standing on lower westwood hub
you cannot
you cannot
save the tip
eventually
it will be inundated if not
by the ocean straight on not by the
sheer height of the water
you can't remove it you're not allowed
to move it
it's a sticking plaster operation
and we have to be ready
to
use the sticking plasters whenever they
need it so far we've only had one
manager incident where the wind blew
from the
northeast
and
exposed the tip on the side
it is just there it is within meters
moment
not under threat that you can actually
go down and you can see that the pebble
is trying to reform further out
thank you
[Music]
it's not just a few meters from uh from
the ash but it's actually right on there
as council rule says when it was last
exposed there was um
there was about a three meter vertical
wall of sand with a one meter wide seam
of rubbish all the way down through
mainly plastic and a lot of it was from
the old different toy works that used to
operate from the king rule so we know
they're from cleveland sorry so we now
know exactly where the edge of the tip
is and it is literally
right on the uh
on the edge of the uh the sound where
the pebbles uh front up against there so
that's it's good in some ways because
tomorrow
night that
the tip was
anything like this close to the estuary
is what what it actually is so we now
know that
um it is a major problem um
it has to be defended and the scripture
law says it can't be moved
when i say county booth i mean
nothing is impossible but it's
it's uh you know it's 55 acres of a form
around uh landfill site and you would
have to get permission from the
secretary of state to actually take it
to another landfill if you could find
them which you won't
and nearly 15 years ago
the latest test the estimated cost of
moving it then was a hundred million
pounds and that was a figure from ed
shaw who was the devil potential
engineer
so clearly
it is a big issue but the issue that i i
was going to mention rather than the
actual tip
was a problem that we have now and i'm
fully in support of this
topic
but the issue that we've got right now
is that southwest water continually
when there's heavy rainstorms in the
area continually allow the the estuary
to pollute to be polluted
they are allowed apparently to dump
virtually untreated sewage into the burn
that runs in front of the uh the first
tee on the on the golf ball and then
runs out in the estrogen and they've
done that for years and they continue to
do that
so i support this motion but in some
ways
the the one group of the one in the one
group that should be
safeguarding exactly
you know this on everyone's behalf or to
make one of the main producers
come to lansing
just a couple of things that the last
point that councillor bushby's raised
is we did actually follow up after um
external scrutiny had had a presentation
from southwest water
um one of the
independent members had raised questions
which he didn't feel have been answered
and we actually um forwarded further
questions to southwest water which is
specific regard
to the issue of um the discharge of
sewage now the answer and response that
has come back from them
is that this is only done
very very occasionally not as frequently
as the um
one out at
cornbread yes cornbread
and it is heavily diluted by rainwater
i think it's something that we need to
keep the pressure on southwest water as
part of our undertaking here to ensure
that this is not done and it is screened
appropriately
the first uh issue though with regards
to the tip
is that the strength in the local
authority special interest room
is that it's not only
uh the groups that they've got with the
notice of motion for the ocean but it's
groups they have got that are working
with government
under a banner of a hall to arms
for all the coastal resorts that have
got landfill sites
because it is unbelievable to think that
historically where did you dump your
rubbish in unused bits of land on the
coast
and there are hundreds of these sites
that are all at risk so it's a
monumental problem
it doesn't diminish the problem we have
here but it is a problem that they
whatever government is in power
sooner or later is going to have to
address
so the strength of joining with
uh the special interest group as an
authority
is he the potential is enormous
to enable us to say we are a member of
this group and we are working with you
so um
i don't think that actually resolves the
problem today
but it may well do in the future
councillor christie
thank you yeah well it's interesting to
hear about the tip um i'm glad two
councils who brought up the uh sewage
because
uh some years ago now we had a joint
committee with north devon looking at uh
sewage and pollution in the river
at that time we did ask southwest water
what was the carrying capacity of
cornbread
and they refused to tell us they're
private company now you can't give your
freedom information
and yet our local plan
has all these houses coming and we
and we seem to be exacerbating
the problem
just by allowing all these new houses to
be built and i don't think cornbread can
take it this is why we're going to get
further surcharges of sewage into the
austrian into the ocean and this is
something i think we need to look at in
our local plan as much as anything and
we need to ask southwest water what is
the carrying capacity we've asked it
many times they won't tell us
and yet
you know i think it's already reached
its capacity it's maximum
i think it goes deeper than that in that
a few weeks ago
in the western morning news i think it
was
they did publish the fact that a lot of
sewage works had overflowed so many
times in the last year or two years or
whatever
that the western morning news had got
some of this information that you would
like and i would like
um so it must be somewhere on the
internet
it's finding it doesn't it
sorry i think you're referring to the
surcharging of the series when they're
when the stuff goes into the river um
what i would like to know is can
cornbread actually
carry or are we going to get more of
these surcharges because
if cornbread isn't up to it then we're
just going to get more surcharges it's
that's what we need to find
out yes so um
so i think it's a valid point you make
about capacity i can't comment um on
what capacity that remains or otherwise
in the system the southwest water
environment agency are obviously key
stakeholders and kind of constitutes the
plan making process so i think it's
something that is entirely valid to
bring up with them as we make future
allocations of housing land and other
land because obviously waste comes from
resources but
i think it's very
valuable councillor hudson
just very briefly i was horrified at the
external scrutiny meeting
um that my lack of understanding and
planning
that southwest water was not a statutory
council t
when considering a planning application
and considering the severity of the
discharge into our oceans
and the amount of building that is going
as councillor christie has just alluded
to
are going to be meeting up with
cormorant
um
i ask the question why
and what are we as a council going to do
about it it's all very well talking
about
the review of the local plan but that is
well into the future what about these
uh planning applications that are
actually on the table now
that are going to be joined up to
discharging into our oceans
very brief one of the main contributions
factors
on a normal day like today the sewage
treatment plant at the moment
works well there is no discharge the
problem we have is this new type
of rain of course it's almost like a
monsoon rain we get sudden bursts of
rain and the storm effect which is
greater than it used to be and that's
what completely overwhelmed these these
sewer treatment ones they're designed to
handle it
you know
as it's needed
and i i don't know whether the
increasing capacity
of the serious fight will actually
rectify that fact
i mean it's vast and we've got so much i
mean all these new mistakes
in this area we do not separate at all
and it all ends up in the same drain and
that that means the huge floor in the
system that we're not moving from the
victorian age
so
that would be so for the the already
built facilities
under new development there are drainage
strategies there's so there needs to be
a sustainable drainage strategy for the
site which is why you find attenuation
ponds and we'll take one of buckley road
as an example
so the the surface water runoff is
attenuated on site and then gradually
drains to the to the natural environment
so it shouldn't happen from a new
development
thank you i'm reassured
chancellor bush has been
thank you and
george
100 spot-ons and we're expecting to
leave and it's been a long long time if
uh since uh
uh rainfall has been a load into the
sewage system it is as he says a
completely separate uh treated in the
second turkey set away which really
exacerbates the point that kosovo
christie is made you know
what is overwhelming
the the sewage system at the moment is
the sheer volume of service that that is
going into this international sewage
system and that is from houses yes it is
made worse by
prolonged and heavy rainfall because
obviously the older properties there is
still an amount of water that goes in
you know the more houses that are
allowed to be built
the you know the bigger this problem is
going to get i mean clearly
you know it's um it's common sense to
you know you can't really argue against
that if you build another 2000s you've
got
a far
greater impact on that sewage system but
you know when it's said that this
doesn't happen very often if it happens
once it's too often when you look at the
volume that we're talking right here i
mean it's just it's you know the stream
that goes from you know from the pill
into you know the yesterday it's quite
wide you know it's ten feet wide in a
lot of places and you know four or five
feet deep there's a huge volume of water
that flows out
and at times when the discharge is in
that in that stream it is absolutely jet
lag faux smelling and kills every living
thing that is in that stream and i've
seen that loads and loads of times over
the years
christie i think we wanted
said he was reassured by being told
about sustainable urban drainage but uh
my mind goes back to morton park where
rmt was actually got dragged into it
because it failed
and we keep pointing this out and
nothing happens and the environment
agency
in my ward they've looked at the kenwood
dam they'll decide it doesn't need
raising sustainable urban drains can
solve it all
if you want
it's been formally proposed i believe by
councillor hodgson and was seconded by
councillor christie
i'm gonna put it to the vote those in
favor please share
that is unanimous thank you
which means i think that we've come to
the end of the meeting
uh
oh